being a fan of Game of Thrones is like
living in the middle of a minefield of
spoilers well brace yourself because
we're about to lay some more down I'm
Kate and this is your gamespot news
update HBO has released the first photos
from the upcoming season of Game of
Thrones which begins this April as is to
be expected they're filled with spoilers
they reveal who is alive or not at least
at the start of the season as such you
should stop listening right now if you
want to go in without knowing anything
and you also might want to stay off
Twitter where these were first shared in
the images you'll find looks at Santa
and Theon having survived their full
Jamie looking upset over the apparent
death of masella who we see back at
King's Landing Arya who can't see
anything and Ramsay Bolton looking as
punchable as ever among many others have
you read the books are you excited
surprised disappointed or intrigued let
me know in the comments or come and find
me on Twitter I matter how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot
you